This is a download from BBC Learning English to find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English, I'm Sam and I'm Georgina.
Something that affects almost every woman at some point in her life is the menopause.
The menopause is a natural part of aging that happens as a woman's hormones decline and she
stops having monthly periods and being able to get pregnant naturally. With the menopause comes
physical signs. These vary from person to person and often include hot flushes, mood swings and
night sweats. But besides these, there may be other changes too and living through it can be isolating
both personally and professionally. In many societies the menopause is still taboo,
not talked about in public for social or religious reasons or because people are uncomfortable
discussing it. But recently high-profile women like former first lady Michelle Obama have started
speaking up. In this programme we'll be hearing from two other women trying to make the menopause
more visible in society. And of course we'll be learning some related vocabulary as well,
but first let me ask you my quiz question Georgina. As we mentioned the menopause is part of the
natural aging process and usually occurs between the ages of 45 and 55. But what is the average age
for a woman to reach the menopause in Britain? Is it A 49, B 51 or C 53? I'll jump in the middle and say 51
years old. Okay Georgina we'll find out the answer later in the programme. Since the menopause is a
normal and natural part of life it's surprising how little it's talked about. Dr Niggat Arif is a
British Pakistani family doctor specialising in women's health. According to her the silence
around the subject is because menopause is about getting old, something no one wants to be reminded of.
Here is Dr Arif explaining more to BBC World Service programme the conversation.
Historically particularly when it comes to women the older you are you're surplus to excess now.
That's it you've done your dues you've had your children your use isn't needed anymore in society.
But actually women are not like that at all women are far more the coming productive in the
career and workspace and they are the caregivers. Sometimes they are actually the financial
providers in their home setting as well. In many cultures the traditional role of women is to have
children. Dr Arif says that after doing this women may be considered to have done or paid their dues
an expression meaning to do everything you are expected to do or to have done your duty.
After raising children women are sometimes thought to be surplus to excess something which is
more than needed or in other words surplus to requirements a phrase meaning no longer required.
Of course this isn't true for all women everywhere but it is surprising how unequal men and
women's experience of getting older can be. Barbara Hannah Grofferman is an American writer who
publishes a regular newsletter the Menopause cheat sheet which focuses on healthy aging.
Here she is speaking with BBC World Service programme the conversation.
One of the biggest complications I think is ageism so if women are entering that age range 45
and over they are already possibly feeling the effects of ageism pointing in their direction.
And then when they add on this layer of having these physical symptoms that can impact
how they are functioning at work or even at home it is a double whammy.
For Barbara Hannah Grofferman one of the biggest barriers women face is ageism the unfair
treatment of older people because of their age. Just as racism and sexism discriminate against
people because of their race or gender ageism values older people less than the young.
As you mentioned before the Menopause brings physical signs such as hot flashes or night sweats.
These signs are known as symptoms things wrong with your body or mind that are signs of some illness
or bodily process. So Menopause or women suffer physical symptoms as well as possibly
dealing with discrimination based on their age. Barbara Hannah Grofferman calls this a double whammy
and in formal way to describe a situation where two unpleasant things happen at the same time.
The Menopause can be a difficult time in a woman's life but with age comes wisdom and experience
and in more and more societies around the world that Menopause is being talked about more openly.
Speaking of which what was the answer to your question, Sam?
In my quiz question I asked about the average age for British women to reach Menopause.
I said it was C51. Which was the correct answer, although for some women Menopause can start as
early as in their 40s. Okay let's recap the vocabulary from this program starting with taboo,
something which is forbidden for social or religious reasons. To pay your dues means to do your
duty. surplus to requirements means to be no longer needed. Ageism is the unfair treatment of
older people because of their age. Symptom is a sign of illness. And finally a double whammy is a
situation where two unpleasant things happen at once. That's all from us but we hope to see you
again soon. Bye for now. Goodbye!